كانت ماريا إيزابيل كروز هيرنانديز
تكافح من أجل التنفس مرة أخرى في مايو عندما
اتصل ابنها لأول مرة بسيارة الإسعاف
التي شاهدناها وهي مريضة بالسكري تبلغ من العمر 72 عامًا يتم نقلها ونقلها إلى المستشفى وبعد أسبوع أصبحت واحدة من أكثر من 46 ألف مكسيكي
لديهم  مات من الطمع 19.
إنه رقم مذهل للوفيات وهو
الآن ثالث أعلى معدل في العالم
بعد الولايات المتحدة والبرازيل فقط
وبالمقارنة مع بقية العالم
، فإن معدل الوفيات في المكسيك ،
فإن النسبة المئوية للأشخاص الذين أصيبوا
بفيروس كوفيد وتوفوا
هي ثلاثة أضعاف النسبة العالمية.
طلب متوسط لشرح أن مسؤولي الصحة المكسيكيين يش
رون باستمرار إل
شيء واحد أن ال
مراض المزمنة هي السبب الأساسي ور
ء زيادة حدة مرض كوفيد في ال
كسيك ، قال نائب وزير الصحة إن
لحكومة تقول إن ما يقرب من ثل
ثة أرباع الذين ماتوا بس
ب الفيروس في المكسيك لديهم  كان لديهم
حالة موجودة مسبقًا ،
وهي الحقيقة التي نراها في المكسيك
،
وذلك لأن السكان المكسيكيين لديهم الكثير من
المشاكل مع
السمنة مع  يعاني من ارتفاع ضغط الدم ولكن
لا يمكن تفسير خطورة كوفيد المميتة هنا
فقط من خلال المرض المزمن ،
يوضح هذا الرسم البياني أن البلدان التي بها معدلات مماثلة
لمرض السكري في المكسيك
هي الأعلى
حتى الآن وبين البلدان ذات
الحجم السكاني المماثل في المكسيك ترتفع حصيلة الوفيات
فوق البقية من
خلال التركيز على  يقول منتقدو الأمراض المزمنة
إن الحكومة
تنقل اللوم بسهولة بعيدًا عن
عامل رئيسي آخر
تقاعسها عن العمل ، هذا مجرد
حكومة سيئة
، يدير الدكتور فرانسيسكو مورينو سانشيز وحدة الاستجابة للفيروس
في مستشفى خاص بمدينة المكسيك
، ويقول إن الحكومة
ببساطة لم تكن كذلك.  مستعد لمواجهة هذا الوباء ،
يجادل بأن الافتقار إلى الرعاية الجيدة عبر
نظام الصحة العامة المترامي الأطراف في المكسيك الذي تديره الحكومة
أدى إلى فقدان العديد من الأرواح سواء كان ذلك
بسبب نقص الإمدادات أو نقص
الموظفين المدربين بشكل صحيح ،
وهذا مرض معقد للغاية نحتاجه
جيدًا للغاية  يقوم أطباء العناية المركزة بالعناية
بالمرضى وهذا اللوم يقول إنه يقع صراحة
عند أقدام  حكومة لا تزال في بعض
الحالات
لا تتخذ الخطوات الصحيحة
للتخفيف من هذه الأزمة ،
وهي حكومة يقودها الرئيس أندريس
مانويل لوبيز أوبرادور
الذي قال هذا مؤخرًا عندما سئل عن سبب
عدم ارتدائه للقناع
، كما قال إذا كان سيساعد الآخرين.
افعل ذلك ولكن لم يتم إثباته علميًا ،
لذا فإن قائد أكثر من 120
مليون مكسيكي يقول إن الكتلة لا
تعمل
وهو أمر خاطئ تمامًا
الآن ، تدافع الحكومة باستمرار عن
استجابتها لفيروس كورونا قائلة إن
هناك
رعاية كافية في المستشفيات العامة مثل
هذا ولكن ما إذا كنت تعتقد أن
الأرقام لا تكذب أم لا ، فإن حصيلة القتلى في المكسيك
هي من بين أعلى المعدلات في
العالم وهي تزداد سوءًا أنهار مات
سي إن إن تيخوانا المكسيك